Speaker 1: Really interesting.
Leaked documents show that at least in some
context, the US government is considering
socialists, terrorists alongside sort of neo-Nazis.
This is a very, very interesting report that
I want to look at with you today from The
Intercept written by Ken Clip-On Steen.
U.S. military training document says socialists
represent terrorist ideology.
A Navy training document asks anarchists,
socialists and neo-Nazis represent which terrorist
ideological category.
We're going to look at the document in a moment.
The article explains a Navy counterterrorism
Navy counterterrorism training document obtained
exclusively by The Intercept appears to conflate
socialists with terrorists and lists the left
wing ideology alongside neo-Nazis.
A section of the training document, subtitled
Study Questions includes the following.
Anarchists, socialists and neo-Nazis represent
which terrorist ideological category.
The correct answer is political terrorists.
A military source briefed on the training
told me.
Let's take a look at the document briefly.
This is a training guide.
It has an introduction which explains that
the assignment sheet is designed to assist
the student in attaining knowledge necessary
to perform the duties as an assigned antiterrorism
officer.
And one of the study questions is indeed the
third question.
Anarchists, socialists and neo-Nazis represent
which terrorist ideological category.
And as can Clip-On Stein says in the article,
political terrorists is the answer that is
there.
It's just ineffective training because whoever
is directing the Navy anti terror curriculum
would rather vilify the left than actually
protect anything, said the military official
who spoke to Ken, who was not authorized to
speak publicly despite the fact that the most
prominent.
That is domestic right wing terror.
The article also notes both the FBI and Department
of Homeland Security have identified white
supremacists as the deadliest terror threat
to the U.S.
We've covered that extensively before.
In October 20 20, DHS issued its first annual
Homeland Threat Assessment Report stating
that white supremacists were exceptionally
lethal and will remain the most persistent
and legal lethal threat in the homeland.
In September, FBI Director Christopher Wray
said the white supremacists have been responsible
for the most lethal attacks over the last
decade and that they comprise the biggest
chunk of our domestic terrorism portfolio.
So there's definitely more here that we don't
know.
But I can't think of any reason that you would
have neo-Nazis and socialists in the same
category.
Now, somebody, if I were to steal man this
and come up with the best possible explanation
for why they would be in the same category.
And again, I don't think this is a good steal
manning of it, but one could say while you
can have a neo-Nazi ideology and not go and
commit terrorist acts and you can also have
a socialistic ideology and not go and commit
terrorist acts, both are ideologies which,
if taken to a perverted end point, could lead
people to commit real world acts of violence.
But I think it's essentially B.S. Socialism
know, I am not a socialist.
I don't believe that socializing the means
of production and that saying that if one
starts a business and buys all of the equipment
and rents the office space and takes the legal
risk and on and on and on, that as they hire
employees, they should be forced to divvy
up ownership of that business to everybody.
Like, I don't I just don't agree with that.
I think it's OK for markets to direct resources
in most cases, although there are some areas
like education and health care and in some
senses maybe housing where we should take
them at least partially out of the market
or completely in some cases, like I'm right
there with that, but I am not a socialist.
I just don't see how that leads to so-called
terrorism in the way that neo-Nazi ideology
does.
Now, I understand there's many neo-Nazis who
just sort of like sit at home and they, you
know, maybe tweet stuff or post stuff, but
they don't actually commit any real world
acts of terror.
I understand that.
But I really even in trying to defend this
as strongly as I could imagine, one could
the inclusion of socialist beliefs and neo-Nazi
beliefs under the same category.
It doesn't make any sense to me.
And so I'd be curious to hear from people
in the audience.
How can you can you come up with some way
to defend this?
And I'm seeing one other defense, which is
kind of integrating socialist socialist beliefs
with antifa and saying, well, antifa does
real world violence, OK?
But I, I think it's still a stretch because
while I think it's relatively uncontroversial
to say that Antifa is not just based in antifascist
beliefs, but heavily inspired to some degree
by Marxism, including socialism on the list
of terrorism, seems like five or six steps
forward from that.
Like I did the best I could to say what is
a way that we could defend this?
I can't think of one.
So I want to hear from you.
And we'll have more on this on The David Pakman
Show Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show.
It's not making sense to me, guys.
It seems completely wacky to include neo Nazi
ism and socialism under the same umbrella.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'll follow up if I have some interesting
responses.